hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand lime waifu and today
we're looking at the face of a human who
is in love and has remembered his person
oh and he's dying let's get into all the
reasons humans suck episode 134 and we
got treated to all the extra reasons
humans suck and before the episode even
started properly i was mad because of
the use of the concept of humanity and
inhumanity so i want to talk about that
for a moment humans cannot by definition
be inhumane not in this context right
because we have another sentient
communicative species who's related and
can be used for a direct comparison
so we can't call human behavior inhumane
because it becomes tantamount to calling
certain behaviors monstrous
and that doesn't make sense at the best
of times but it makes even less sense in
this context where we have what people
would call
monsters these ants are supposed to be
our analog for monsters but how can they
be if humans are called monsters because
they're doing things that don't fit the
definition of human and
being called inhumane for it you see
it's a cycle that makes
no sense and so we have the great
destroyers
also known as humans doing what humans
do which is crush each other the way
they crush bugs and
ain't that awful this entire episode was
about humanity and ant
life and the understanding or the
question of which one marowan favors
having watched the episode i think he
favors
ant kind i think he managed to avoid the
worst parts of humanity and has managed
to
supersede the bloodthirstiness of
humanity the part where we just destroy
and kill because we don't see any other
way out of conflict
the fact that the poison they're all
being affected by is continuing its
chain of destruction is pretty horrific
the idea that it's a combination of the
ant poison you can set down that they'll
take back to the nest and like
just decimate a nest and standard bug
spray is quite disgusting so when that
poison chain of inhumanity comes up
i would argue that actually it's the
most human thing that could have
happened because the ants wouldn't have
even thought to
do something like this nor would marowan
want to do something like this
something this devastating the humanity
of this matches the behaviors we deem a
lone wolf or isolated incident or
a monster did it like we we say those
things
but who or what created the monster the
culture the monster grew up in
anything that humans can create is
perfectly human including this horrific
bug bomb which is going to kill will
kill
everyone in fact at some point i mean
and the first thought i had upon
realizing how far-ranging this poison
can go is
um did they consider what happens if he
goes to human civilization because i'm
sure the humans either didn't think
about that or did and either one of
those is an
awful awful consequence that continues
to point toward how
awful humans are perf's life is very
complex right now and seeing the slow
process of death through his eyes
is interesting in fact given how to date
we've had characters understand
everything about their impending doom
and think about it as it happens
there's a lot of power to that concept
here we have three people who are going
to die
standing over the body of their fate on
a small yoopi
one thing i loved about this episode and
the way it was animated is that we
legitimately had a moment and frankly
speaking the whole episode was a soap
opera about mirowem's eyes
everything was dramatic turns and new
information for meroem and that's
actually quite fascinating considering
we spent so much of the time
not seeing any reaction from him at all
and then combine that with perf
legitimately saying
i must find a way to lie by telling the
truth the cuteness of welfan's thought
process is that he had to think so very
hard
to say literally the one thing he was
sent to do and for that
for that wealth and for that wealth and
we stand
we stand even though he had to do what
god did and age up a whole lot to do it
like let's not forget he aged up he did
he did a gone for that
he did a gone he changed the outcome of
the whole damn thing
welfin is the true hero here that and
his desire to find his king
who i still believe is meruem but
without knowing it and that there is the
point where i think meroem surpasses
humans to become
ant because in walking away from welfan
what he was doing was allowing someone
who defies him to survive
there's no ego there yes he's distracted
by his impending advancement on
his field child but he's also uncaring
of the things that humans get so caught
up on which is
hey this guy insulted me to my back how
dare he
i am mad let fight now and at that point
wolfen has more than redeemed himself
and has shown both the loyalty and
hostility that
perceives coming from him and he's right
meruem is unstoppable except by the
poison which will stop him eventually
it's just about how quickly given how
powerful he is and how many people he
messes up before he does and between
them
the king and perth love the classical
drama of self-sacrifice without actually
sacrificing themselves to anything
up gave literally of himself to meruem
and grew smaller and weaker for it it's
interesting to me that perth did not
actively become smaller which does make
sense because he wasn't full size when
he did it but his power was largely
maintained for a very long time
i don't really understand it but it is
interesting from a consumption point of
view speaking of
consumption welfan's fear of being eaten
made him an unappealing meal which is
possibly the best way to avoid being
eaten and is highly adaptive
the idea that his first and last moments
was so significant to him put him on a
par with meruem who
has one thing he wishes to do and one
thing that he's gonna do
and that one word therefore stands for
everything
kamugi it represents love care
compassion emotion
heartbreak it's all there in that one
word and it's so
potent that even perf understands it he
understands the value
he finally understands that he's a
sacrifice he understands that the
loyalty he's sacrificing himself too
is giving more than he gave in every
other power all that energy he used just
to see how much the king loves her
if we learn anything perf is more human
than ant in those moments but seeing how
much the king values kamugi helps him
realize perhaps how much he values his
king regardless of what merome decides
to do with his life and so let's move on
to episode 135
um my heart i was right i guess though
that's small comfort kamuki did
essentially kill him she was his
downfall if he hadn't been focused on
her
he'd have prepared for attack he
wouldn't have sent pito away from him to
save her puff wouldn't have put energy
into killing her
and yet we wouldn't have had the
heartbreaking climax to this arc that we
got the political side of the situation
reasserted itself because humans are the
true monsters we get that we were lucky
enough to learn that not enough of the
right people died and that others did
who really shouldn't have i
am so mad so shaking mad about bizarre
surviving but you know
yeah and let's ignore that because this
entire episode was about love and we're
not going to find that in humanity
meruem found his girl he got the girl
and he died with her almost like an
antigone in the cave
if haman had died with her instead of
leaving her to her fate alone
as perf's wings flew off into the breeze
it made it really clear to me that he
died as a human
while the two in the dark died as ants
with the beautiful fireflies of
searching around them
i can't even begin to say how beautiful
this episode was and i kind of don't
want to say how beautiful it was because
how am i supposed to quantify it the
whole arc was dedicated to understanding
the difference between human and ant and
at the end we're left with two creatures
who entirely eschew their
respective entities to just become
precisely what they were
in the dark by the end meruem couldn't
see either by the end merome had become
as weak as kamugi but stronger than all
those he left behind he was still the
most powerful creature in the world
because he had abandoned all sense of
hatred and hostility left to find
contentment in the woman he loved and
then of course we have palm
who simply wanted for him to hurt her
essentially she simply wanted him to
give her exactly
what she was used to exactly what she
expected she wanted to be
destroyed she wanted to be hurt she
wanted to be used she wanted
him to be cruel to her but it turns out
that ants simply
are not that ants are he only wanted one
thing
and he did everything he could to try to
get that she just wanted to watch true
love and so
she got to he's part human she's part
ant and
they both got what they wanted i feel
bad for palm because at the end of all
of it all she wanted was to be
cared for and to be loved and she
couldn't even have that and now she's an
aunt and it's almost as though she has
more capacity to love and more capacity
to care and more capacity for
everything else and she doesn't have
that she doesn't get to have that the
stripping of all the honorifics was
again a beautiful touch the passage of
time as shown by the credits rolling
with memories of their time together the
fact that meruem never beat her at the
game that she's
so totally managed to conquer him the
shift in art to softness and the
darkness at the end
all of it contributed to the closing of
a beautiful arc and i
thoroughly enjoyed it i find i almost
don't care what happened to gone and
keela because
we have our love story ending i have no
idea what the last few episodes are
going to be because
to be honest i feel as though this was
the best ending the series could have
had
yes there are loose ends and i still
kind of want to know what happened to
hisoka
and i don't know kurapika and lyorio and
kiwa and gone i guess i guess maybe but
i'd be okay with this ending
given the protagonists change and
frankly everything feels complete and
yet i probably will be back to watch
more because i know there is more but
not today because
that's it from me if you enjoyed this
tearful trip down memory lane
like share subscribe do all the fun
things talk to your friends and i'll see
you
next time